why is the 3 better than the 2 well
maybe the difference between them is not
so visible from these two generated
images but rather here why can the 3
create so many details we have specified
in the thanks prompt well it's mainly
because the3 trained on better captions
than Del 2 but we do not know every
other technical Improvement since the
technical report from open AI does not
contain too many details about D 3 as
the authors kindly point out in footnote
5 on page 10 in this video we will see
what we know about ali 3 and how a
simple trick helped Ali 3 become so much
better at following prompts than its
predecessor but first let's thank
gradient the sponsor of today's video
I've always wondered how a bank or a
hospital could use a large language
model to give capable answers about
things that are stored in their private
databases especially since their
Industries are so complex well gradient
is here to help gradient offers out of
the box industry expert llms that come
highly tuned for specific Industries
like Health Care financial services and
compliance even more through simple API
calls you can find un llms and combine
them with your own private data to
improve the model skill and
understanding of your organization you
can also use retrieval augmented
generation where the llm can look up
things in your proprietary database
while generating the answer I know
Industries like healthcare and finance
are highly regulated so luckily gradient
is both s so 2 and Hippa compliant which
is great for D but it's also great for
du since gradient is gdpr compliant and
you deploy within your private
environment so your data never leaves
you check out gradient in the link in
the description below now back to the
video di 3 is out it is a defusion model
that you can use as a chat GPT plus user
and through beinging chat here is a
short timeline of how open AI progressed
image generation since
2021 January 2021 open AI released di
one which generated images with an auto
regressive Transformer basically from
top to bottom the pictures look good but
where small resolution and without many
details and also a bit blurry December
2021 they switched to diffusion models
with glide that generate an image from
noise step by step we have many previous
videos about diffusion models if you
want an explanation for them see the
playlist finally Glide was not yet named
like an offspring from di one because
they are architecturally so different
but then April 22 open AI decided to go
full in the fusion models and leave the
auto regressive Legacy of Del 1 behind
and release Del 2 which is a modified
Glide model incorporating clip
embeddings and now since August 2023 the
3 became available for just re
researchers and as of October for a
wider audience through Bing chat and
chat GPT plus its ideas are building on
latent diffusion models the architecture
in stable diffusion released August 2022
with researchers from LMU Munich and
Runway ML and now you will see what
exactly open AI has disclosed about di 3
well not so much about the architecture
since it's a latent diffusion model
based on a unet and uses T5 for encoding
the text Pro
but further technical changes are
undisclosed but now the interesting
training trick of Del 3 that the authors
describe is about its training data
because what was the problem of Del 2 it
had troubles following the prompts
exactly it misunderstands them or misses
details and this is no wonder because
the image caption data sets are scraped
from the internet so they contain images
and their alt text as caption since me
and you do not even remember when we
last wrote an extensive and descriptive
Altex for our website pictures it is no
wonder that these captions are short
talk mainly about the image subject but
miss out on details about the whole
scene the surroundings background and
all the tiny details in it so because
the training data does not have lengthy
and detailed descriptions the diffusion
model is bad at details because it has
never been exposed to them so the idea
here for Del 3 is to take the existing
images and generate such lengthy and
details captions synthetically and then
train the diffusion models on those but
how to create these synthetic captions
well by using an image captioner
basically a Transformer language model
with clip image embeddings as input
image captioners like this one are
really good these days but also they
reflect the training data for short and
undetailed captions so it was still
reluctant to describe the details of the
image so the author's fine-tune the
captioner on a small human written set
of elaborate and detailed captions that
describe many things in an image the
subject in detail then the background
and the whole scene the colors the
objects have the style of the picture
and so on with this image captioner they
recaption the training data set of di 3
and trained di 3 with 95% synthetic
captions and 5% actual captions written
by humans and yes the authors ablated
between 80% 90% And 95% synthetic
captions and found that 95% gives the
greatest similarity between real
captions and the generated image but
what about 98% we do not see how this
would play out in this graph this simple
trick of synthetically making the data
better helped a lot because human
annotators preferred Del 3 over mid
journey and stable diffusion XL version
one in the author's human evaluation
experiments the authors also show a
stable diffusion like Baseline models
that a model trained on synthetic
caption still produces images similar to
human written captions because here the
blue line of the model trained on
synthetic captions is not very far away
from the yellow line of a model trained
on human generated captions when it
comes to the similarity of the generated
image to the real Caption This
similarity is computed by the clip model
by embedding the generated image through
Clips visual branch and embedding the
caption through its text Branch
therefore it is called clip score
also the model trained on synthetic
captions the Blue Line increases the
similarity between the generated images
and the synthetic captions which is
expected by design of the training so
yeah this was the simple trick making
the 3 so good at following prompt
details and it was all about synthetic
data the trick is so simple no wonder
that Google research published the same
idea of synthetic captioning just a few
days after the open AI paper came out
you can check it out it is very similar
and even the experiments from Google are
on stable diffusion just like open AIS
so synthetic data looks like a good idea
so far though we are wondering how far
this can go and whether the image
captioner introduced some peculiarities
in the text prompts that people could
then eventually exploit after all we
have seen in a previous video how with
each step of training a model on
synthetic data its distribution gets
skewed and if repeated many many times
it degrades catastroph ically what do
you think of open ai's technical report
since they do not release what else they
innovated for Del 3 other than the rec
captioning of the training data set I
wonder why they released this idea and
not also the others maybe they just
wanted to release it before Google
research was planning to anyway if you
want to see more videos like this one
subscribe to the channel and see you
around okay
[Music]
bye